frustrated with book challenges and
bands in their school district a parent
in Utah submitted a complaint of their
own about the Bible
now good for the Davis School District
they took the objection objection
seriously they placed the Bible under
review and the district officially
decided to remove the religious text
from elementary and middle school
libraries for containing vulgarity or
violence the ban takes effect
immediately with Bibles being removed
from classrooms even as they close down
for the summer Additionally the Book of
Mormon is now under review as a result
of the exact same thing so let's talk
about what's going on here the Utah book
ban by right Wingers is a case of
censorship backfiring